[Music]
on this monday night omicron case is on
the rise in canada even if you have had
a boosted dose you need to continue to
be careful the new urgency to keep
hospitals from being overwhelmed
as the uk declares an emergency over the
new variant i am apologizing to you
ottawa's long-awaited apology to the
military's sexual misconduct victims my
voice is no longer silent narrowly
dodging a deadly tornado the door was
ripped from a hand stories of grief
and generosity in the u.s plus time
magazine calls elon musk a clown an edge
lord and a showman
so why did it declare him person of the
year
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with developments related to
the omicron variant which is spreading
faster than any other variant we've
endured in this pandemic canada's top
doctor says there is now community
transmission of omicron in this country
it's not just being brought in by
travelers and it has the potential to
rapidly escalate in the days to come the
prime minister is urging people to
minimize their risk
as we look at christmas and the holidays
coming
people need to be listening to public
health advice and making decisions that
minimize their risks because nobody
wants to have another winter in which
our hospitals and our frontline health
workers are getting close to overwhelmed
he is urging canadians to book a booster
dose of vaccine as soon as is possible
it's believed that will give you greater
immunity to omicron preliminary data
suggests it causes milder illness but
there is much scientists are still
working to understand jamie morocco has
our top story tonight
the speed at which kovid's latest
variant omicron is spreading could again
push our health care systems to the
brink
it's very worrisome to think that we may
be facing yet another surge in our acute
care system
in ontario omicron now makes up 30
percent of new daily cases and members
of the province's science advisory table
are worried it may not be as mild as
first thought set to become the dominant
strain in days omicron poses real risks
vaccinated or not even if you have had a
boosted dose you need to continue to be
careful
exhausted from the last two years
hospital workers are preparing for the
worst
like a wild roller coaster
to be honest a ride our overworked
system needs to get off in her annual
report canada's top doctor says this is
the time to do it
we can no longer dismiss the voices or
delay necessary actions there are
increasingly urgent signs that we need
to act now while canada was under
prepared for the pandemic its impact has
left us more ready to react and adapt
failing to focus on our gaps tam says
will only cause our system to further
deteriorate and our children will
ultimately pay the price we won't be as
healthy as we could be the pandemic the
opioid crisis significant mental health
impacts and the health effects of
climate change it's a lot but there's
still time to avoid the very worst
outcomes if it takes a once in a century
pandemic to harness and leverage what i
would call political will to make the
changes necessary that's really i think
at the end of the day what we're looking
at
imploring leaders to maintain public
health investment or risk canadians most
valuable asset
our health
jamie rocker global news toronto
cases of the omicron variant are being
confirmed all over the country now
including at universities in western
central and now atlantic canada as ross
lord reports changes are underway to try
to limit its spread ahead of the holiday
season
public libraries across nova scotia are
carrying a new supply of covet 19 rapid
tests extra protection against the gift
no one wants this christmas omicron
across the country cases are up
and we hoped to be immune
here in nova scotia but we're not the
omnicron variant has arrived in our
region health authorities connect the
highly contagious variant to a covet-19
outbreak at saint francis xavier
university an outbreak that spilled over
into halifax and into neighboring new
brunswick the last 10 days or so
have shown that this virus does spread
very quickly even state effects
president andy heakin has tested
positive and the confirmed presence of
the omicron variant has forced nova
scotia to reimpose pandemic restrictions
from the third wave starting friday
gathering limits physical distancing you
know tightening up on the masking all
these things will be back in effect i
know the timing couldn't be worse with
the holidays around the corner we just
seem to be getting some sense of
normalcy back into our lives and now
there's a new variant and things are
changing yet again
this pandemic is not kind
exams the same effects have been
switched to online or postponed until
the new year omicron's arrival led to a
similar decision at queen's university
in ontario and horizon covert 19 cases
on vancouver island forced the
university of victoria to cancel
in-person exams but nova scotia's
outbreak also strengthens evidence
omicron could be less severe for some
people than previous variants although
we are seeing high case numbers we are
not seeing severe illness and that is
very good news in fact no one in nova
scotia has been hospitalized with covert
19 in almost a week something
authorities say is the result of high
vaccination levels ross lord global news
windsor nova scotia
in the uk the first death from the
omicron variant has been confirmed and
the rush is on to give all adults a
third dose of vaccine in london omicron
is responsible for 44 percent of coveted
cases now and it's spreading so fast
it's expected to be dominant within 48
hours hospitalizations aren't rising as
fast right now but it's expected they
will soon begin to go up today the uk's
covet alert level was raised assigned
pressure on health care services is
expected to be substantial crystal
gamansing reports
the weights are long the worry growing
omicron is fueling a rapid spread of
covid19 cases in the uk
it's spreading at a phenomenal rate the
number of infections is doubling every
two or three days there's going to be a
tidal wave of infection the variant
already accounts for 40 percent of
infections in london and more people are
testing positive for the virus it will
likely become the dominant strain here
in days with all of the strains combined
more than 54 000 infections were
reported in a 24-hour period on monday
that's up nearly 10
compared to the previous seven days
hospitalizations have increased as well
with more than seven thousand having
been admitted 901 are in ventilator bets
the uk has also recorded its first death
linked to omicron according to the prime
minister the best thing we can all do is
get our boosters uh we're opening up
centers across the country we're getting
in the
the army to help with the logistics
demand for the jab led to the national
health service website crashing there's
also been a run on these home rapid test
kits while everyone is aware of the
seriousness of the virus many are
adhering to government advice
so they don't have to change their
lifestyles
uh
not really worried about cover to be
honest
just just get on with it can't stay at
home forever certainly for people like
me for my generation we've had our three
jabs so if we go back into lockdown what
was the point
it was this week just last year when the
prime minister cancelled christmas and
imposed a lockdown in england now
omicron is spreading faster than delta
did then for now the government says
it's a race between the variant and the
vaccines hopes for the holidays and the
new year
now hang on whether that will be enough
crystal gomanson global news
london
the pain
and trauma
that so many have endured
because the very institution
charged with protecting and defending
our country
has not
always protected
and defended its own members
that is defense minister anita anand
delivering a long-awaited apology to
canadians who endured sexual assault
misconduct and discrimination within the
military anand says countless lives have
been harmed because of inaction and
systemic failure the acknowledgment
forms a key part of a 900 million dollar
class action settlement reached in 2019.
abigail beamon reports on the apology
and the reaction
the government of canada did not
keep its most basic promise to you a
40-minute apology delivered by the
defense minister the chief of the
defense staff on behalf of an
institution that has failed you on
behalf of those who didn't listen
on behalf of every person who took no
action
we profoundly and sincerely apologize
and the deputy minister in too many
cases
willful disregard or entitled
obliviousness have worsened the impacts
of harm who touched on her own
experiences as a woman in the navy i
knew that if i had complained if i had
made a fuss and i would not have been
allowed to participate that women would
have been considered weak
that stood out to anneliese shamoon i
found that it was very authentic a
survivor of military sexual assault
shamoon says it's important to hear
senior leaders reflect using real human
language that there was an accurate
understanding of what people had gone
through and i really did feel that
they didn't just stop at oh you know you
were assaulted or you were harassed it
was like all of the aftermath the
retaliation and the
minimizing i feel like for the first
time in 42 years
my voice is no longer silenced that's
how long it took for me
to get to this place today and to be
able to say
that
i believe the minister
the cds and the deputy minister spoke
with sincerity lori bouchard says the
emotional weight she's carried now feels
lightened but she knows there are other
survivors for whom the apology may add a
heaviness and their journey must be
respected this time we will not fail
this is my commitment to you there is
much much more work to do nearly 19 000
claims have now been submitted as part
of the 900 million dollar class action
settlement the deadline for claimants
has passed but lawyers urge anyone with
exceptional circumstances or a
disability to reach out saying there's
some flexibility for late submissions
and while 19 000 is a huge number
survivors stress the actual number of
those impacted is so much larger with
all those hurt by the military's culture
and their families
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the bc government is extending the
provincial state of emergency for at
least two weeks as crews worked to
reopen highways destroyed by flooding
and mudslides and the government is also
lifting the order to ration fuel drivers
had been limited to buying 30 liters per
visit to ensure essential services and
transport vehicles had priority access
to fuel
new brunswick is the latest province to
sign on to the federal government's
child care plan the province says
families will see a 50 reduction in
child care fees by the end of 2022 and
they will pay an average of 10 a day
within the next five years over the
course of the agreement 5
700 additional spaces will be created
ontario nunavut and northwest
territories are the only places without
a deal with the federal government on
child care
a survivor's story from kentucky coming
up one family's wild encounter with a
deadly tornado
[Music]
the governor of kentucky had trouble
finding the words today to describe the
toll multiple tornadoes have taken the
deadliest one cut a 365 kilometer path
along the ground destroying everything
it hit more than 80 people are confirmed
dead 74 of them in kentucky other people
are still unaccounted for and those who
survived have no home heat water or
power in the chilly december
temperatures jackson prosco is in the
small town of mayfield kentucky or
what's left of it jackson
well donna the damage here in mayfield
is extensive and it's incredible it's
like this for block after block where
houses have been absolutely destroyed
but it's like this in towns across
kentucky and that means that people are
not only grieving the loss of their own
homes and possessions but also of the
communities where they live
piece by piece the cato family is
picking up what's left just so that we
can get into the bedroom
and get that stuff out their home in
mayfield kentucky was shattered by a
tornado
the family barely made it to the
basement in time the door was ripped
from my hand and we got around the
corner and we were heading down the
basement all the kids were already down
my husband and i were heading down and
all of a sudden we hear the front door
fly through the front of the house
and we had just got to the basement
floor when we heard the big boom and the
whole house just erupted their house
their neighborhood and their entire town
are gone it was very humbling
to realize
everything that we had
we now have nothing
the tornado that struck mayfield was a
monster carving a 300 kilometer long
swath part of an outbreak of storms that
stretched across six states more than 60
people are confirmed dead in kentucky
alone of the ones that we know
the age
the age range is 5 months
to 86 years
dozens are still missing and hope of
finding any more survivors is quickly
fading in some towns three quarters of
the homes have been destroyed it's just
upsetting you know to know that that's
the town that you grew up in and
everything you know his memories is all
gone
the buildings that survived are heavily
damaged and surrounded by dangerous
debris
yet there is no shortage of people
willing to help in one way or another
okay i need everybody to get down this
is video of one of friday's tornadoes
taken by canadians drew taylor and
alicia cairns near nashville what we
experienced was crazy it was like almost
like a freight train that went over the
building
their home was spared and so they drove
two hours north to mayfield and started
cooking for those who lost everything
it's one thing to see it on tv but to
see it like in person it's pretty uh
it's pretty tragic
in just the past few minutes we've seen
more search and rescue crews with dogs
coming through these houses to make sure
once and for all that there is no one
trapped inside but the job of doing that
right across this state with so many
homes and communities impacted is going
to take some time donna the governor
says it could be a week or more until
they know exactly the status of all
those who remain unaccounted for
all right jackson proskow in mayfield
kentucky tonight thanks
ahead how much is ottawa preparing to
pay to compensate indigenous children
and their families
[Music]
the federal government says it is
setting aside 40 billion dollars for
first nations child welfare and that it
includes money it's been ordered to pay
by a human rights tribunal and lawsuits
the issue has been outstanding for years
it involves children who are
unnecessarily taken from their families
and communities but this is not a formal
settlement michael couture is with me
and has more details mike
well donna setting aside 40 billion
dollars doesn't mean the government has
come to an agreement on compensation for
indigenous children who were taken into
the child welfare system but it is a
signal the years-long court battle could
soon be coming to a close crown
indigenous relations minister mark
miller announced 40 billion dollars will
be earmarked in the fall economic
statement for indigenous child welfare
compensation and long-term reform
discussions on an out-of-court
settlement have been facilitated by the
former chair of truth and reconciliation
commission and former senator murray
sinclair and those negotiations continue
we are cautiously optimistic but they
are fragile um there's issues of costing
there's issues of
of of sorting out amongst the parties um
what that proper
allotment of of compensation is uh and
and and moving forward on a number of
issues that are near and dear to the
parties
mike what has been the reaction from
those parties that have been pushing for
compensation including fighting with the
government in court
well they are calling this announcement
positive but certainly are waiting until
they see the legally binding document
here now these groups have heard
promises from governments before and the
real test will be when they see how the
money is being allocated and what
actions come next i think there's always
a danger of politicians trying to
announce good news and and leave an
impression with the public that
everything is fixed
nothing is fixed right now
there's a hopefully going to be a plan
to fix things but even that is not
enough and while the talks continue they
are running out of time the deadline to
come up with the deal is december 31st
donna all right mike look at her in
ottawa thank you
next time magazine calls him a clown and
a genius and named him person of the
year for 2021.
a former mayor of toronto was laid to
rest today in the city he loved mel
lastman who died at the age of 88 spent
three decades in municipal government
this morning lassman's son said his
father's health deteriorated after his
mother died in january last month
started out as a furniture salesman his
son says he was a largely uneducated man
who started with absolutely nothing
except a dream known for his brash
outspoken style he was mayor of north
york for 25 years before getting elected
mayor of toronto when the city
amalgamated in 1998 lassman retired in
2003.
well he's never been elected to office
but elon musk wields a lot of power he
is intent on transforming how we live
here on earth and off it and it's in
part because he is a disruptor and a
visionary and a mass of contradictions
the time magazine has named him person
of the year in 2021 that seems kind of
fitting here's eric sorenson on why elon
musk is so timely
[Applause]
where to start with elon musk the
awkward but brilliant visionary early
ventures in e-commerce led to paypal his
interest in mars spawned spacex rockets
that can come and go
heralding a future of interplanetary
travel and then there is tesla his
vision for electric transportation
that's turning the gas-fueled car
industry into a battery-powered future
and he welcomes competition if it helps
the climate hope that they also make
electric cars that we can accelerate the
transition to sustainable energy i i'm
confident in the future in tesla that
will do well and
i hope some of these other companies do
well too time magazine describes musk as
both clown and genius the man who
aspires to save our planet and get us a
new one to inhabit
more than a visionary says this futurist
someone who's able to
execute on that vision
and turn that into reality as a viable
and hugely
successful and profitable
entity musk has also courted controversy
the richest man in the world worth over
250 billion dollars his sheer wealth his
penchant for shaking up the stock market
his support of cryptocurrency of all
generated criticism and there are his
weird tweets too which are often
self-inflicted wounds
or humor that i find funny but not
necessarily that other many other people
find funny we also ask my mother who's
here tonight his personal life has
connections to canada his mother born in
saskatchewan he went to queen's
university for a time and his former
partner grimes is also canadian he's
played along with some of the
perceptions i am not the evil i just
misunderstood but musk's imagination
knows no bounds he wants to heal this
planet but has mars as a fallback the
key is
is making this affordable to
almost anyone who wants to go some worry
that one person with such outsized
influence may squeeze out other ideas
and solutions it should be less about
the individual person and more about the
collective well-being and health of our
society but society's mavericks are hard
to ignore and musk is one maverick
inspiring new ways to meet the future
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is the forks in winnipeg we'd
love to see your canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye